♪ ♪
>> Tucker: CHRISTINE FORD
APPEARS BEFORE THE SENATE
TOMORROW AS EXPECTED.
SHE WON'T SIMPLY BE SPEAKING TO
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY,
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, SHE WILL
ALSO SPEAK WITH SEX CRIMES
PROSECUTOR SARAH MITCHELL WHO
HAS BEEN TAPPED.
BUT WHAT SORT OF PERSON'S MENTAL
AND WHAT DOES SHE DO AND WHAT
SORT OF PROSECUTOR ASHLEY BEEN?
THIS IS RACHEL MITCHELL'S BOSS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> YOU ARE VERY WELCOME.
>> HE SENT OUT STATEMENT SAYING,
CLUELESS OLD WHITE GUYS, PICK
SOMEONE FROM SHERIFF JOE
ARPAIO'S OPERATION.
IS SHE FROM SHERIFF JOE ARPAIO'S
OPERATION?
>> NO SHE'S NOT, SHE'S A DEPUTY
COUNTY ATTORNEY WHICH MEANS SHE
WORKS FOR THE MEK
MARICOPA COUNTY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
>> Tucker: WHAT WILL SHE BE
DOING TOMORROW IF CHRISTINE FORD
ATTENDS A HEARING?
>> IF THE HEARING DOES GO
FORWARD, MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
SHE WILL ASSIST THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND TRYING TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION AND TRYING TO GET TO
THE GROUND TRUTH OF WHATEVER
ALLEGATIONS HAVE BEEN MADE AND
TO COVER THE SCOPE OF THOSE
DURING THE HEARING.
EXACTLY HOW SHE'S GOING TO DO
THAT, I'D LEFT HER ALONE AS I DO
WITH MY PROSECUTORS WHEN THEY
ARE ABOUT READY TO GO INTO TRIAL
AND SHE WILL BE DEVELOPING THAT
LINE OF QUESTIONING BASED UPON
HER TRAINING, BACKGROUND AND
EXPERIENCE.
THAT WILL COVER ANY AREAS OF
INQUIRY SHE WILL HAVE TO COVER.
>> Tucker: WHEN SHE SPEAKS TO
SOMEONE WHO HAS ALLEGED A CRIME,
A FELONY AGAINST SOMEBODY ELSE
WHO SAYS SHE'S A VICTIM, IS THE
ASSUMPTION FROM THE PROSECUTOR
THAT SHE IS TELLING THE TRUTH,
THAT SHE'S NOT OR IS IT NEUTRAL?
>> IT'S NEUTRAL.
WHAT RACHEL WILL DO IS GO IN AND
START BY LISTENING, AND IT
LISTEN TO WHAT THE ALLEGATIONS
ARE, LISTEN TO WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING.
SHE CERTAINLY HAS A VICTIM
CENTERED FOCUS AS A PROSECUTOR,
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN'T
ACCEPT IT AS A GROUND TRUTH
EVERYTHING THAT'S SAID.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
PROSECUTORS AND SOMETHING SHE'S
BEEN DOING FOR ABOUT 25 YEARS TO
LISTEN TO ALL THE FACTS.
ASSESS WHAT CAN BE PROVEN, WHAT
CAN BE CORROBORATED, WHAT NEEDS
CORROBORATION, AND THEN, CONDUCT
AN OVERALL REVIEW.
ORDINARILY FOR US AS PROSECUTORS
THAT DECISION IS WHETHER OR NOT
WE SHOULD CHARGE SOMEBODY WITH A
CRIME, AND THAT'S A BASIC
APPROACH IN GETTING INFORMATION
IN TRYING TO ASSESS CREDIBILITY
ON WHAT TYPE OF CORROBORATION
THAT MIGHT BE, THAT SKILL SET IS
EQUALLY APPLICABLE.
>> Tucker: I'VE NOTICED
WATCHING THE STORY UNFOLDED,
ALMOST EVERYONE ON THE PERIPHERY
OF IT HAS BEEN SUCKED IN AND
DAMAGED.
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S CHILDHOOD
FRIEND MARK JUDGE, MOST PEOPLE
HAD NEVER HEARD OF HIM, IS NOW
THE CENTER OF VERY INTENSE
CRITICISM FROM THE LEFT BECAUSE
HE'S BEEN NAMED.
DO YOU THINK SHE'S READY FOR
THAT?
SHE COULD SEE HER OWN CHARACTER
ASSASSINATED.
>> BACK HERE IN THE HOME
JURISDICTION, THOSE WHO HAVE
LITIGATED AGAINST RACHEL, WORKED
WITH HER OR WORKED FOR HER, KNOW
WHAT HER REPUTATION IS.
AND IT'S BASED UPON HER
PERFORMANCE, HER ACTIONS AND HOW
SHE TREATS OTHER PEOPLE.
AND NOTHING THAT HAPPENINGS IN
THE HEARING TOMORROW WILL HELP
WITH THAT.
SHE'S VERY WELL GROUNDED,
PROFESSIONAL, FAIR AND OBJECTIVE
AND WHEN SHE'S DONE WITH THAT
SHE WILL BE ABLE TO LEAVE IT
BEHIND.
THAT WAS A TASK THAT SHE WAS
CALLED UPON TO DO, AND THEN IT
WILL BE DONE.
JUST LIKE PROSECUTORS HAVE TO
MOVE FROM ONE CASE TO THE NEXT,
PARTICULARLY IN THIS AREA WHERE
HER BACKGROUND IS SEX CRIMES,
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH
THE CASE, WORK WITH THE VICTIM,
AND SEEK JUSTICE FROM THE
ACCUSED, THEN GO TO YOUR NEXT
CASE.
>> Tucker: SEEK JUSTICE.
NO ONE IS SEEKING JUSTICE, I